all right Steve see boat where'd you
grow up where you from originally
however I didn't do it when Los Angeles
California
tell your family no I never had a father
my mother she was she was a good
provider but she was a lousy protector
she didn't protect me from people that
would hurt me when I was abused
throughout the years uh by my uncle he
was a drug addict an alcoholic and he
would just go crazy on me you know it's
just a little boy
I still have scars on my legs today from
when he used to hit me with a phone
cords and extension cords my parent my
mother she would keep me out of school
for the week because she was afraid of
children's services taking me away
somebody would see the scars yeah so she
didn't let me go to school because I was
bleeding all in my head and things like
that and I didn't get it back then why
she kept out of school but now that I'm
older I know why because she was afraid
they were to take me away I wish they
would have because maybe now I wouldn't
be in a situation that I'm in now how
many of them you know made better
choices she says to say the same is if
my father was around maybe somewhere
down the line he could have guided me in
the right direction instead I chose the
streets I never finished high school
I chose drugs industry life over my
family I have children that are grown
now I've been out of their lives I've
never been a father I don't know how to
be a father
and I sort of blamed my father but I
can't put all the blame on him because
I'm an adult amount and I know the
difference between right and wrong but I
never had a father so I don't know how
to be I'm 40 years old my daughter she
will be 21 and in March I have two
younger boys or 13 and 11 I have the 15
year old son and I've never done
anything for them because I've talked to
my daughter here and there but because I
wasn't ever there for her she's doing
her own thing you know she's into the
gang life
and I blame myself for that
because if I would have been there maybe
I could have stopped her from joining a
gang my two youngest boys I was in and
out of their lives because I chose the
streets over my family once again and
their mom couldn't take it anymore so
she let me go and I understand why
I don't know how much family I haven't
seen my mother since 2011 I have no idea
where she is
my grandparents don't know where she is
no one knows [ __ ] ever since my little
sister passed away it's like she forgot
about me she forgot that she still had
one child up
and
how'd you lose your sister
I was told that she was addicted to
pills and her whole internal organs
everything shut down that's the story it
was given to me when I was in prison
I was such a terrible brother to her and
I felt so bad when she passed away I
still carry that guilt of treating her
so bad
wishing I can go back in time and change
things and be a brother to her I tell
her all the time all the time how sorry
I am for not being the big brother that
I should've been I couldn't stand my
sister I don't know why I just couldn't
I couldn't stand being around her and
when she passed away I felt so bad
the last time I saw her she came down
here and she tried to get me to come
home and she cried because I refused to
get in the car and go home with her
and that's the last time I saw her so
that Gil is always gonna be in
I'm always gonna feel that Gil I'm not
going home with my sister when she cried
and she pleaded for me to come home and
get off the streets
[Music]
any help
I've been downtown for a long time
and I don't know why I'm still you and I
know I don't have to do
I'd give anything to start all over
again to make the right decisions
I had people in my life they tried to
guide me to do the right thing
but I was already hooked on the streets
the excitement the lifestyle
but now that I'm 40 years old
isn't that fun anymore it's it tears you
down and it wears you out sleeping on
the streets every day sleeping in a tent
or on a sidewalk or something like that
it takes a toll on your body
[Music]
the worst thing that happened to me when
I was bit by a brown recluse spider and
it nearly took my arm off where this
happened this happened
yeah I've sounded down here
this happened 2018 my arm got really big
on my elbow and it still hasn't healed
that's from the skin graft oh yeah
they took color off my leg and just put
it in my arm because when they cut off
the flesh
it was just pink so they did what they
could with my leg and put it on my arm
did you lose the arm yeah it goes all
the way up here my whole entire own
yeah she has healed all the way this is
2018 but because I'm out here on the
streets and I'm not taking care of
myself
the way I need to the process is taking
a longer go you what do you think would
have changed your path and you were a
kid what are you dad obviously think so
you know I'm not gonna say that I would
have made the best decisions because he
was there but something would have been
changed heaven your dad was a good role
model
yeah better wait yeah
yes I feel so bad because I let myself
down and then my grandparents down
anybody that ever cared about me I
disappointed him they don't they always
had high hopes for me I was an honor
roll student
I didn't start making bad grades until
junior high school once I started doing
drugs and hanging with the wrong crowd I
would give anything to go back and
change that I started hanging out with
gangs at a young age
then I became a gang member game ever at
one point but as I got older I got tired
of didn't I don't know there's no point
in gangbanging because either going to
jail or you're gonna die one of the two
there's no no benefits from gang banging
none whatsoever
I wanted to be a part of something I
wanted to be a family
[Music]
I feel like I might hear all about
myself now because I don't know where my
mother is
and my father stays in Denver somewhere
he's never wanted to be a part of my
life anyway he's involved with all his
other children but me I'm the only boy
he has all girls I'm the only one he has
nothing to do and I don't understand
that
how did you do that to me
I've tried to be a be a part of his life
but he didn't want it
he pushed me away his even my
grandmother his mom will get upset and
talk talk to him about neglecting me and
he's like that he would still
leave me alone
I just want to start over again
I'm born euro now and I have nothing to
show for it
I've been to four different colleges and
I didn't finish
Eddie over because the streets kept
calling and I take that back to the
streets they think I can do both and I
can't and I see that now
I'm well I'm what you would call a
dysfunctional addict I can't take care
of my business and still live that
street life I'm not
I can't do it
what drugs do you use crack cocaine in
the past I've used PCP marijuana
I've tried crystal that I don't really
like it
I just want to start over
I want to go back to when my sister was
still alive she died when she was only
25 and I had no idea that she was sick
so when I heard about it when I was in
prison it destroyed me because all that
kill just came down on me at once
I felt so bad by how I treated her when
we were kids and I tell her how sorry I
am all the time it's her how much I love
her
she will be 37 this August
and I miss you so much give anything
just to hug or tell how sorry I am
thank you
downtown has been the downfall of my
existence there since I stepped foot
down here it's been all bad for me
I can't it's hard for me to stay away I
do good for a little while and somehow I
love coming back here anyway and I know
my sister is disappointed in me because
I'm still here
I don't know what to do
I'm not into the gays anymore that's one
thing I can say I don't know
it is
I just want to start over I said
I can't believe I made it to be 40 years
old after all the things I've done I've
done a lot of things in my life that I'm
not proud of I mean the majority of it
is altar up where they did your first
time went to prison was for a violation
and the second time went to prison was
for strong-arm robbery
it was all behind rugs everything
[Music]
I gotta get clean I need help
I've been in the programs before but I
never finished something I always leaves
the program the things like that
but I started thinking maybe it's time
that must I go to one and stay
and nothing can happen but good when
you're in a program I mean it's better
than this
I've never had a job for more than six
months I've never been able to hold a
job because I once again I thought that
I could live my street life and still
take care of business it's all a lie I
can't do it and I've had that much
that's that mindframe since I was a
teenager thinking I can do both things
and as you get older people start to
care less because they see please see
that before they feel that you're never
going to change your such-and-such years
old and you're still doing the same
thing so if I go to jail I don't have
any support anymore
because they're the people they cared
for me they're tired they're tired
they're they don't trust me anymore
and I can't blame anyone but myself I
caused this to happen I chose to do the
drugs and drink alcohol and things like
that and do the things that I've done in
the past so many people not trust me
I want to change
I'm gonna do something to make my kids
proud
to make my sister proud
and most importantly to make myself
[Music]
I gotta start somewhere
[Music]
I just don't know where to start I've
been in jail more times downtown than
I've ever been in my whole life
it's all behind drugs
I don't want to die down here I've seen
a lot of people die down here
whether they were killed or they died of
natural causes because they've been out
here for a long time I don't want to be
one of those people but I feel like I'm
going to be one because I'm still here
still here
[Music]
well if this is going out to the social
media
for those who are
really pay attention don't take life for
granted
cherish every moment that you have with
your family your children your mother
your father grandparents because they
can all be gone
with the snap of a finger I have no more
family I don't know where anybody is
anymore
my grandparents are dying
you know they want me to do is do better
and I can't even do that before they
died
so I just stay away from the because I'm
tired of disappointing
and one
Oh
my advice to all the parents out there
watch your kids very close
pay attention to their activities make
sure they're not hanging around the
wrong people they shorted out doing
drugs or they end up like me
[Music]
Thank You somebody talking to me coming
yeah
I don't know what else to say I've just
I need all emotional wants to start
talking about my grandparents and my
kids and how I haven't haven't
accomplished anything
the only thing I've accomplished was to
create more grief for myself
to all the parents love your kids as
hard as you can
be there form listen to them
acknowledged in
and let them know that they can always
come to you when they need someone to
talk to
you never pushed him away always lift
them up
that's all I can say
[Music]
if any of my family is out there
watching this my children
anyone who ever cared about me I'm so
sorry
for not being there I'm so sorry for the
huge disappointment that I've become
I'm sorry
please forgive me that's all I can say
thank you
this beer thank you